how's it going everybody as I mentioned
before the closer we get to the trailer
of Avengers 4 and the actual movie
coming out we'll get more leaks
concerning the movie and today we have a
really awesome new leak for Avengers 4
we have a leaked photo that confirms
that Pepper Potts will be rescue in
Avengers 4 quick heads up I'm still
giving away copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero
so today Gwyneth Paltrow has delivered a
major spoiler to us
she took a selfie in iron man armor
confirming that she will in fact be
rescue in Avengers 4 this was already
widely speculated due to some leaked
photos a few days ago that showed what
looked to be a female Iron Man suit in
the comics Pepper Potts finds a secret
room of Tony's and what she then finds
an Iron Man suit that Tony made for her
she calls the Iron Man suit rescue and
uses it many times in the comics I think
fans have been waiting for Pepper Potts
that dawn to rescue armor in the MCU for
a pretty long time now in Iron Man 3 we
got a little closer to Pepper Potts
being involved in combat but it was very
very brief and kind of a letdown to fans
hoping that she would actually dawn the
rescue armor in the movie so this will
be great news to fans because as you can
see in this photo she is absolutely
wearing rescue armor she is already kind
of leaked that her and Tony have a child
in the future perhaps a new threat
coming in Avengers 4 threatening the
well-being of her child is what causes
her to put on the rescue armor whatever
the reason may be it looks like we're
going to see Pepper Potts put on her
rescue armor in Avengers 4 so let me
know your thoughts on this and how
excited you are to see rescue in
Avengers 4 in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you